tell us about charter fleet com what is
this design to do so base we show sweet
home is a comparison site so we've got
over 350 yachts on there that you can
just basically browse through and choose
your next C for holiday basically so
we've got yachts ranging from 50 meters
plus and ranging in price from let's say
150 thousand up to a million basically a
hundred and fifty thousand dollars we
per week and that's just a step foot on
the yacht right now is this gonna say so
okay
that maybe gets you to the dock
basically to put your foot on the yacht
and then what happens and then of course
you would have put pay for your crew for
the food on top of that the dockage
everything alcohol as well the fuel
where you want to go because sometimes
it is quite expensive once you start the
engines to move from one island to
another of course it is definitely so
that's what Charlie is designed for so
it helps you out with whatever you want
to know about chartering the yacht so we
speak to captains to get the bespoke
itineraries they get to find out about
all the secret destinations you can go
to the secret beaches or the beach curbs
etc it's basically a comparison sites
know what if you want to take your own
beach club with you because a lot of
these yachts they come with their own
toys and these toys can be very
elaborate the toys are fantastic on
there but what you can get nowadays is
amazing and this everything what a jet
ski ski from you've got the triton
submarines which are basically a private
submarine that you can go down to the
depth of the ocean maybe thirty meters
below it and sit there and sip champagne
while you're watching the the underwater
world go by it's amazing but let's talk
about some of the individual yachts just
as examples let's start with the Lady M
Lady M obviously a lot of celebrities
like to charter sea Piazza's just what
they like to do but also a lot of
superyachts are involved in big
Hollywood blockbusters lady M was in
wolf of Wall Street last year she was
the basically the yachts that the broker
used to have that sailed and she
actually sank but Lady Anne was actually
used in the Hollywood film which is a
fantastic yacht she sleeps about ten
people I've leave
and has a range of amenities on there
from the jacuzzi on top to the awesome
toys she's a great all-around yacht to
charter all right let's talk about
another one that's for charter a hundred
and eighty one feet of Germania nova
yacht she's absolutely beautiful
she's a sailing yacht and she's got a
great story behind her as well so she
was basically perked
she's an exact replica of Germania which
is 1908 built racing yacht and when she
was built back then and she raced in so
many so many races and won almost every
single one she was then taken as a prize
of war sailed over to the US and the
owner then had a bit of a problem and
Sankar but Germania Nova was built to
basically as a tribute to Romania and
now she sails around the Caribbean and
just absolutely stunning let's go for a
giant one something that's over 200 feet
shere khan is that expedition yacht and
the reason you charter yacht like shere
khan is for the adventure i think why
she's so special is because of her
itinerary she's doing around the world
of venture next year she's going to a
place like Patagonia just going to
Antarctica to the Galapagos she's a very
very special yacht and of course when
you're doing an itinerary like that you
have to have some fantastic communities
on board to keep people them used when
you're doing the crossings so when
you're at sea for a long time you have
things like the amazing spa which is at
the bottom of the yacht you've got the
steam rooms on there the jacuzzi you can
even have a massage if you like as well
and then the swimming pool is on the top
deck has a glass bottom as well
she's pretty fantastic and that goes for
what about five hundred thousand a week
about half a million a week I just undo
that yes it's a lot but they all don't
have to be expensive right I mean you
can get much less expensive charters
with super yachts you can I mean
Germania Navy I think it's around fifty
thousand dollars a week base price to
get on there so you can get for a lower
price like that but generally they are
pretty pricey vessels because you've got
to pay for the fantastic
amenities that are on board and of
course the crew as well the chefs are
some of the
chefs in the world work on these charter
yachts they have to be able to make
anything that you desire